Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to reading your comments. SHHHII-HEH--*explosions*
"If you have a sibling you've been blackmailed at least once." I don't know if my brother would agree to that, let me call him.
Thomas: Hello?
Mark: Hey dude, I'm recording a little video. Have you ever blackmailed me or have I ever blackmailed you? Thomas: Blackmail?
Mark: Yeah, blackmail.
Thomas, laughing: I don't think so.
None that I can think of.
Mark: Yeah, 'cause everyone keeps saying that if I have a sibling that I must have been blackmailed at least once so
if there's that do you want to blackmail me now?
Thomas: What?
Mark: Well, do you have anything that you want to blackmail me with? I don't want to be left out of the loop.
Thomas, laughing: I don't know. I've got that funny picture of you with... nah.
No, I don't... I've got... nothin'.
Mark: You got nothin'? T: Yeah. Mark: And everything I do embarrassing is already on the internet.
Thomas: That's what I was thinking,
It's like nothing I could think of could really top that...
Alright, I'll talk to you later then. Mark: Okay
Bye. So, no, I've never been blackmailed.
"Run into the pool and scream 'my lovely lady lumps!'"
*sarcastically* Okay, alright, off to my pool I go. ♪My humps! My humps! My lovely lady lumps!♪ SPLOOSH
Lalala Lalalala, oh no! Is that a--
TSUNAMI?! *scream*
*moaning?* ohhhhh
*drowning noises* Blblblblblbl
Heavy: DED.
Mark: I don't have a pool anymore, so that's the best I got. "Can you play the guitar for us please?"
Okay! *awkward strumming* Ahhhh, that's out of tune!
Also, it's electric, so it's really fucking not hearable, great stuff.
I've been using Rock Smith's to practice
and that's fine and all but it's really not the way I want to play guitar
so I'm gonna be getting another acoustic pretty soon, and I want to be picking up a finger-picking style, kind of like, I don't know,
folksy, whatever you want to call it.
I don't know where I'm gonna go with it, but I've just been falling into music lately, and it's been really really nice.
It's super weird, It's Ed Sheeran and Bruno Mars right now,
I have no idea why but I just really... I don't know, I'm getting into it.
I never really pursued music before but now I'm just starting to fall in love with it again. So, heh, I dunno. "Where is Subnautica?"
*intense music and voice* Find Subnautica!
Where could it be?
WHERE IS IT?
wHeRe IS--oh wait, yeah, it's right fuckin' there, it's right there.
"Mark, don't look up turtle mouths!" Well now I gotta look up turtle mouths.
*amused but disgusted laughter* haHAAhahaa!
Why? Oh my god, why? WHY?
Euuuuuuughhh... OUUUUUUGHHH.... Euheheheugh....
Why'd you have to do that to me??
"Mark, how long did it take you to get used to not feel weird talking to a camera?" Umm,
It took a while, like it took a while, if we look back at one particular video of mine,
it's one of my earliest vlogs and uhh...
...it was a little bit awkward. "Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and on today's show we talk about
4,000 Subscribers, the end of the world brand new reaction compilation,
4,000 Subscribers,
that's incredible guys." These few times when I did a
"vlog" I did 'em on my T3I up against my white wall with only daylight coming through the windows.
I had no idea of what I was doing and I had no idea what I was talking about, so I kind of just
went with it,
just be--oh my god this face here.
But I kind of went with it just because it was something that I felt like I needed to do as an update.
I had to do this over again like five times
just because I didn't know what I was going to say, but back then, you know, it took a long time. This was
somewhere in the range of two to three months of me starting back into, or
starting to do YouTube videos, so when I came out of it
I really didn't know but I got more comfortable as time goes on just because a camera is very
impersonal you're talking to a machine
So you know that what you're saying isn't exactly translating across so it's not like there's another person there, so
Trying to treat a camera like another person is really really hard skill, but I'd say about
No six months to a year before I started to get comfortable
And then almost two years before I was fully fully comfortable hey mark
Can you please please please get a musical e if you do my username is sid shaw I do have a musically
musically is
Fuckin Litt Bruh right there. I've got my musically
I've got videos up there right now that you want to see you want a taste of the good stuff
If you want to find me on musically go look up at Nod markiplier on musically. That is my
Profile so they'll get it and go watch it and follow me there because you can expect all sorts of musically goodness
From me to you. It would be a shame if you suddenly tripped
Okay, my lumps my lumps my lovely oh, no
Trip birth
Spin Spin
Oops, will you be doing another Mario Kart 8 deluxe video with Ethan?
I love seeing you guys crash into everything and making goo jokes
well
You can look out for more goo jokes coming your way with me and ethan coming at you with some Mario Kart 8 action I
Do want to do another one again? That was a lot of fun, so
Expect more of that
but hopefully we will have
Matured enough not to make goo jokes by the time we get back now who am I kidding is Gonna?
Make goo jokes till the day I die if you could be a rapper
What would your name be by the way love your vids? They're like a rapper name generator' oh?
My name is Marek my last initial is f use nickname alright here. We go Boink Marky M
Fatal Aka manic dog cut damn that's a good rap name. How about another one plast?
Blaster Mf nugget Spewed Emf cookie yes, please just take the mf out of there. I'm spoony cookie
That's my rap name. I'm spoony cookie all day pusha mf Cool. Hey K MC guns
Dr.. M Markie M sharpie
Aka lucid flash, okay. Well any one of those are good, but you know my favorite. Oh coconuts. Keep sucking the grass
Mark how deep can you make your voice go? Oh?
oh
Not really like much voice down there, so taking pick whatever voice actually was there. Hey mark. Are you going to bring unnecessary?
Censorship back to be perfectly honest. I forgot that series entirely existed
Completely and absolutely forgot that unnecessary Censorship was even a thing on my channel
I'm going to bring that back
It's a weird question, but did you outgrow your lucky flannel shirt like physically like you can't wear it
Or do you think he left it in another Era of Markiplier?
And it's better off there no the truth is actually much sadder
The truth is it was stolen and and and that wouldn't be such a big deal like it was stolen
That's fine like I took it off when I was at a convention at some point
And then I set it down and then it was gone and someone has it out there, but the worst thing is that
Specific shirt is not sold anymore. It was originally a
Target not even a flannel. It was actually not flannel. It was a very specific material
There's a lightweight. Plaid it was so comfortable
It was perfect, and it's not on sale anymore the company that made it
I believe it was Massimo the company doesn't make that version of that shirt anymore, so what it is is a classic and
Unfortunately, I just don't have it anymore. I've tried to get other flannels, but they're not the same
It's not the same hey mark first. Thank you for the amazing videos. I love watching them now
You said many times that you like to innovate and try new things on YouTube
But is there anything you would never do in a video. I don't know I'd like to think I'm pretty open-minded about things
It's mostly things that I couldn't do
Because I would love to try anything like I'm not afraid to get embarrassed and try new things especially if they don't work for me
But when it comes to things, I won't do I won't do videos that hurt other people. I won't do videos that
Intentionally embarrass other people I'd say that's only the limiting factor
I will do anything to embarrass myself, but when it comes to affecting other people. I really don't want to embarrass them otherwise
I'm an open book if you come you got a type of video that you want me to do laying on me makeup tutorials
Unboxing videos, I don't I'll do it all because that's that's the thing I like about Youtube
It's an open book I get to do pretty much
Whatever. I want whenever I want and that is a super freeing experience and because of that
I'm able to stay happy in making what I want to make I always am
Happier when I get to try new things
And I think that is the key to any project if you're doing any sort of art art form
YouTube's not exactly an art form for me
but you know it's a fun expression of creativity and
I I think that's a beautiful thing so in whatever you're doing out there and whatever I'm doing
Just keep trying new things
Always try to learn and always try to push yourself
Beyond what you could do before and then you'll never stop moving so anyway. That's all the time. I got for reading your comments
Thank you everybody so much for watching this has been an enlightening experience
For both you and me but I know there are more burning questions in your mind
So if you've got questions
If you've got requests if you've got challenges for me to do write them down in the comments below
I would love to read them all and try and I handed them
So thank you again everybody so much for watching and as always. I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye